We weren't able to communicate with dad
really all of September. My mom is is
her best friend and her husband.
>> What about the gins, man? They have
families as well like you. They have
families like you. What about them?
Look, look, look how emotional you are.
Just imagine the people back in the day
when they would have to travel certain
distances for months or even years. What
is one thing that they would carry with
them? The Quran. Why? because they did
not have it on their mobile devices or
their gadgets. Brothers and sisters,
imagine you have a app, the Qurani app,
which not only shows you how much
rewards you get, but reminds you to read
the Quran. Gives you reminders. Download
the Quran app now and let it testify for
you on your Makyama that you read it
wherever you was.
To brothers and sisters and dear
friends, um I don't like to uh be upset,
you know, or I mean be happy about
anyone's misery unless they're Zionist.
Yes. I'll be honest with you, you know,
um it's not that something that, you
know, it's like something that I
celebrate like this that I'm not I don't
mourn it at all. And who is this? No
other than Jordan Peterson. Yes. And I'm
not certainly not mourning it at all. It
doesn't phase me at the least. Even if
I'm not happy about it, I'll be honest
with you. I'm not sad about it at all.
I'm I'm so damn far away from being
inside ever. Yes. Okay. I'm more close
to happiness than sadness. Why? Because
this man is such a shameless man. Anyone
on this planet earth that condones the
killing of innocent men, women, and
children, you are psychologically and
mentally unstable. If you make excuses
for innocent men, women, and children
being massacred, you are out of your
mind. I don't care if you're a Muslim,
Christian, whatever you are. If I saw a
Christian genocide happening and I'm
just like, "Oh, yeah, but it's just the
Muslims are doing it." So I'll turn a
blind eye. I'm sick in the head. I'm a
sicko. And our religion doesn't teach us
that cuz we're morally consistent. Not
strategically. We don't say, "Oh, how
does that benefit us?" We're morally
consistent. So guys, here's a video of
his daughter. I haven't even forgot her
name. What's her name? Chem Muel. I
don't give a damn. Let's watch it for
ourselves and let's see what's the
condition of the man who said give them
hell. Let's see if Allah gave him help
or is giving him help. And we ask him,
and it's not never too late for him to
turn to Islam. Michaela Peterson. Yes.
Who is another Islamophobe, I'll be
honest with you. He was sitting and
sharing platform with absolute morons.
Yes. Like a flipping dumb clown. Uh
Apos. But anyways, let's go.
>> Hey guys, I have an update on my dad.
I'm actually just going to read this.
It's on my teleprompter
because this is too hard to explain off
the cuff. So, I wrote it out. This
summer's been exceedingly difficult.
Dad was in an ICU suffering from
pneumonia and sepsis after dealing with
a host of neurological issues this
summer that we believe stemm from SERS,
which is chronic inflammatory response
syndrome due to decades of mold
exposure. We don't have a better
explanation for his neurological
symptoms at the moment other than
spiritual attacks.
>> Interesting. spiritual attacks. I don't
know what she means by that. Spiritual
attacks.
What do you what do you mean by that?
Because I really want to understand what
do you mean by spiritual attacks?
Because at the end of the day, I mean,
can it be a divine punishment?
Most certainly because do you really
believe the divine God Almighty is happy
with any servant of his? They can be
Christian, whatever for that matter.
Yeah, we're all his servants. Do you
think he is happy with any servant of
him that says give them hell to innocent
men, women and children who are in the
biggest prison open air prison in the
world who've been massacred for decades
and do you think God's going to be happy
with that person? Do you think that
person going to prosper? Do you not see
IDF soldiers saying they're losing their
mind and they see nightmares and they're
suicidal? Do you think you're just going
to get away? Do you think Allah says in
the Quran, do you think Allah is unaware
of what the evil doers do? He only
delays them for a day that their eyes
are going to look in horror. So either
they get punishment in this life or the
hereafter or both.
>> He's been suffering for the last number
of years with unexplainable neuropathy
and weakness amongst other symptoms.
>> Unexplainable. Interesting. I wonder
what it is. You know, I wonder what it
is. You know, to me it's nothing but
divine punishment. I'll be honest with
you.
>> But they worsened this summer after he
cleaned out his parents' basement after
his dad, my grandpa, passed away.
We weren't able to communicate with dad
really all of September.
During the end of the pneumonia, he was
diagnosed with critical illness
polyuropathy,
which we're hoping is critical illness
myopathy, which is bad enough. That's
been heartbreaking and brutal on top of
everything else. But after almost a
month in the ICU, he's been moved out to
a less urgent floor.
>> Don't forget to download the Salah Pro
app. Absolutely free. brother and
sisters free kibla finder ads free salah
reminders encourages you to pray salah
you can book a salah instructor order a
guided prayer mat find your local salah
habs watch videos on how to pray it's
all there for free inshallah
[Music]
was it heartbreaking for you did you
ever come out to speak against the
Zionist regime and what they're doing to
the gods and people heartbreaking for
you your dad who's old enough lived his
life if he passed away okay I understand
it's your father Yes, he's lived his
life, whatever. But have you come out
once and condemned the Zionist and the
IDF? Huh? When those innocent babies
were being blown into pieces where their
mothers were picking up their limbs and
identifying them by their limbs, did you
come out as a woman and say there's
woman being massacred? Yes. No, you did
not. But you're sad. Yes. Cuz it shows
your hypocrisy.
>> Praise God for that.
>> Praise God for that. So, you need to
repent to God for that. You need to
repent to God for that. We're still in
the midst of this, but now we're seeing
improvements daily. The timeline for his
full recovery is hard to tell at the
moment, and I'll update everyone when we
have more information. My family's
asking for prayers. Like I said, this
summer's been exceedingly difficult and
terrifying. Dad's condition is
complicated by the fact he can't take
most medications without suffering from
severe paradoxical reactions, which
limits treatment options.
Like I mentioned, I believe there's a
spiritual element at play here. I think
a lot of people have felt it in the last
few.
>> Of course, it's going to be a spiritual
ailment. You are saying give them your
dad said give them hell. If it's not
going to be spiritual ailment, what else
do you think it's going to be? The
reason she's saying spiritual because
they have noticed that the doctors can
diagnose it to be something physical. So
that's what they're like is something
spiritual. Of course, it's going to be
something spiritual. If you are evil and
if you are condoning and and a genocide,
turning a blind eye, you are as good you
you're a silent Satan. Yes. And not only
being silent, promoting it, give them
hell and this that
months. It's been hitting my dad and my
family hard this summer. In August, the
day dad was brought to a hospital by
ambulance, my newborn Audrey was also
brought to a hospital by ambulance
within hours of each other.
Look, you have a little child. Yes. And
you know how it is for a mother or a
father that their child is ill. Did you
have any of the empathy when he looked
at that child and said, "Wow, imagine me
being robbed off my house, be kicked out
of my house, and my child being
massacred. How would you feel if you
thought of the girls and children?"
Nope. You never do.
>> It was unbelievable.
This was the second time this summer we
had brought Audrey to the hospital after
she almost died from near heart failure
at 6 weeks old. That is exceedingly rare
and they couldn't find a cause for. She
was diagnosed with idiopathic pulmonary
hypertension which seems to have
resolved. Praise God. But it's not
something that
>> and we ask God almighty to protect your
daughter. Yes. Because you guys are not
our teachers. We would never want any
harm to come to her. She's innocent in
this. Yeah, we Muslims are not, like I
said before, we're not um strategically
considered morally. We would not want
anything that's been done to the garden
to be done to your children. So, we ask
God Almighty to protect your child and
possessing to a mother like you who can
who at least has a platform that can
come out and speak. Oh, unless she's
like, oh, you know, might get
cancellation of deals, you know. We even
heard your dad is now suing Ben Shapiro,
you know, cuz he went bankrupt. You
know, maybe he was there for the money,
you know. I don't know why he's suing
him otherwise. happens. You know, this
was late July after dad and I recorded
some episodes of the call-in show
together.
Everything went just really downhill
fast after that. Every single day this
summer and now fall has been like
watching a movie. Our families relying
heavily on the Lord through this and
seeing miracles around us. We are. And
I'm also aware that God uses everything
for good. So eventually we'll see why
this is happening or what comes of it.
But mom and I in particular really
wanted to reach out and ask for prayers
to help everyone get through this.
Especially for my dad and for my mom,
but also for the nurses and doctors
taking care of him. My brother and
family and friends who have come to
support us. I miss my dad. My brother
misses his dad. My mom misses her best
friend and husband.
>> Okay. So you are sad. Okay, I
understand. You've lost your you're
going to your your father and this etc.
What about the gazins man? They have
families as well like you. They have
families like you. What about them? Look
look look how emotional you are. I
understand. I understand your pain. But
look at that. So much so you didn't even
cut this bit out. You wanted people to
see how painful
>> how painful it is for you. Yes.
>> I thought I wasn't going to cry during
this.
>> Look. And that is what her father is
going through something spiritual.
Whatever it is for that matter. Look how
distraught she is. What about the guards
and children being blown into pieces who
have orphaned who become orphaned? Their
mother of fathers have been killed. What
about them? What about the kids being
shot at? Target shot from snipers. Do
you cry for them?
No, you don't. No, you don't.
[Music]
Well, he's hopefully recovering and like
I said, I'll keep people updated. He has
a team of people, including myself,
continuing his mission, including
Peterson Academy, and will be releasing
his We Who Wrestle with God tour to
everyone on YouTube, which he's wanted
to do for a long time.
And given we think there's a spiritual
element at play here, we believe the
right way to fight back is to keep going
and push harder if anything.
>> Okay. Yeah, we got spiritual ailment,
but we are going to push back. How you
going to push back? by saying kill them
more. I don't understand like some my
friend my dear friend me said here he
said for some reason everybody ascribes
God to them like yeah God's on my side
I'm a Muslim I can say God's on our side
but if I'm doing something evil I would
say I don't think God's on my side with
this one you know if I came and said
there's a Christian genocide or a Jewish
genocide and I said yeah give them help
I would and if I was hit with a
spiritual ailment I would say you know
what I think I don't think Allah's happy
with me here cuz Allah doesn't quote for
that you know I think Allah trying to
teach me a lesson I should change my
ways not double down on it
>> life isn't necessarily supposed to get
easier when You're doing the right thing
and I can see God's hand throughout
this.
>> You can see God's hand throughout this
and you think you're doing the right
thing. Are you are you psychologically
okay? You think you're doing the right
thing? Your dad was doing the right
thing by saying give them hell.
Like, are you kidding me? Is this the
Jesus? You're Catholics. This is this is
the Jesus that you worship. Love your
enemies. Forget they say the greatest
form of hatred is Christian love.
>> But it's a lot to handle.
My family agreed or wanted to delay
updating everybody because a lot has
happened over the last few months and we
were hoping he would recover faster and
we would see bigger improvements sooner
and have better news and it was really a
near-death experience
for a long time. So, we've been just
dealing with this one day at a time. We
still are. It's been overwhelming, but
it looks like and we're praying that
things are headed in the right
direction. He's out of the ICU. So,
that's the main thing. He's out of the
ICU. Um, like I said, praise God for
that. Thank you all for listening. Thank
you for the prayers. Thank you to
everybody who's reached out. Um, I'll be
back
on YouTube
maybe in the next month or so, depending
on how things go. Um,
yeah, that's the update. Thanks, guys.
>> That's good. I found it interesting as
well. There's a little sheep there, an
innocent sheep, animals. You know, I'm
so sorry. Nothing you put there or
angelic thing is going to make you your
father or yourself look innocent. And
Allah says in the Quran, I'll end with
this and this is the city they have. Oh
believers, do not associate closely with
others who would not who would not miss
a chance to harm you. Their only desire
is to see you suffer. Their prejudice
has become evident from what they say.
And what their hearts hold is far worse.
We have made our revelations clear to
you if you understood.
>> If only you understood.
>> If only you understood. What they say
and what they have in their heart is far
worse. And you know what? You are not
our teacher. Like I said, the same for
Charlie Kirk. I'm most certainly going
to not mourn your illness or whatever
you're going through, but you're not our
teachers. We don't learn from you. We're
not as evil like you guys. So, like I
said before, I leave the matter to Allah
and like I said before and Allah, God
Almighty will deal with oppressors. So,
like I said before, you wished hell for
them. We're not going to wish hell for
you. We will leave it in the hands of
God. If God determines hell on earth for
you, let it be. And hell in the
hereafter, let it be. But we leave that
matter to God Almighty.